absolutely I think it's always important
to speak of generalizations in general
and to understand that all
generalizations are only true in general
a third of white guys out there a voting
democratic can have for decades but when
you understand that when talks one
talked about demographic groups and
you're talking in general and you keep
it only within that context I don't
think it's it's not only not wrong it's
it's it's true often and it certainly
grinds against our desire to not if you
will predefine anybody and that's you
know basically not thrust a stereotype
on to any one member of a group there
there's still one in ten
african-americans in vote Republican
there's still at least thirty to
thirty-five percent of the Hispanics
will vote Republican I predict in the
two thousand presidential race despite
the illegal immigration issue so yeah
it's important not to thrust these
generalizations onto these different
demographic groups not all white guys
are you know Bubba Joe Sixpack but I
would emphasize him that it's the left
that is actually among these white guys
actually thrust the stereotype onto them
I as a mess as my book they these men
often felt like Archie Bunker they often
felt like they were defined as Archie
Bunker sort of a bigoted overweight guy
who's a little bit sexist in a little
bit racist and the Democrats were like
you know we're losing these elections
but we're doing it for the good fight
you know we're doing it for good reasons
we're losing for altruistic reasons so
it's it's okay that we lost but we did
the right thing and the problem is if
the Democrats looked at their loss of
their majority in the last 40 years and
they simplified it they said what we did
the right thing on civil rights on
women's rights the later on gay rights
and for doing the right thing if we lost
our majority it's okay that's childish
one they lost their majority for reasons
that predate Democrats taking up the
civil rights movement and there were
indications of this as early as 1928
when Republicans one in nineteen twenty
half the South publicans one half the
South in 1928 on civil right I mean on
cultural issues alone by painting the
Democratic candidate out of New York as
a big city politician Against
Prohibition a Catholic against you know
the values of the Protestant south and
it's as certainly some of that veered
into xenophobia but it it it was a great
lesson that even the south is not as
simple as some just racist block it
never was and it certainly isn't today
and so when you look back the last 30 or
40 years the Democrats one simplified
how they lost a majority and basically
it was like I compared to a marriage and
when you have marriages sometimes you
hear someone describe the break-up you
know what you'll hear at a table if
you're around your friends and one
person describing their breakup you know
you'll hear basically I've heard some of
my female friends literally a brunch in
the city talk about a breakup and it's
like this guy is a total jerk and so
just read any men do this as well but
the problems the Democratic Party did
the same thing they blamed the divorce
of these men from the Democratic Party's
solely on these men you're a big at your
racist or sexist some of the pushback of
my book has been essentially we don't
need these men they're bigger to racist
or sexist they represent an old America
there are what there's lessening number
of Americans there's still thirty six
percent to the voters in the coming
general election and to these many of
these men they were like you know what
we're not perfect too many of these men
but like it's not all our fault in other
words the divorce occurred for reasons
for mistakes on the left as well and
it's important when understanding how
you ended one relationship to accept
some fault and to look at those mistakes
you made because that's going to help
you mend that relationship and and
certainly have your next relationship
and that's true for the Democratic Party
as well at this critical moment when
they can truly do build a new majority
and certainly the danger of a book
focused on Hispanics or men or women is
that you you create these like you
helped enhance these stereotypes but I
only believe that's a danger if someone
reads a book in a very superficial level
and actually doesn't read the whole
thing and I think a lot of these books
clearly show
that clearly you know while showing what
appeals to these men shows the
exceptions and my book does that as well
at times clearly demographics matter and
there's never been a better case of that
than the 2008 Democratic primary race
which is stunning for how much it breaks
down purely on demographic lines I
emphasize how we clinton would not have
won in New Hampshire or Nevada for
example if it was not for white women
and the overwhelming support of white
women especially New Hampshire Barack
Obama would not have won South Carolina
if it was not for the overwhelming
support of african-americans so people
voted in demographics at some sense
sometimes these white guys have clearly
shown that they won't just vote for a
white guy as I said the Democrats have
putting forward white guys for a long
time and they haven't done too well but
what was most stunning about white man
in the demerits loss of these men in the
last 40 years more than anything was
that when I looked into the gender gap
when I took a deep below and went deeper
I did every socio-economic group there
isn't anything I master where was
education levels high school post
college educated weather was income
level so it's making less than 50,000
filming come more than 200,000 in
between it didn't really matter whether
it was broke downs of region south
northeast even sometimes by state what
was clear to me and what was most
stunning is the white male gap
transcended every demographic group
there wasn't a post college educated
white male group that was leaning
democratic there wasn't a family under
thirty thousand dollars of white white
male men who were majority leaning
Democratic whether it was a margin of
ten percent or margin of twenty five
percent the fact is that the margin
transcended region where you live
suburbs xserve city and it transcended
what states who lived in and it
transcended how much money you made and
so see that fact and to not say what is
going on here what is particular about
these men's outlook on the world that is
estranged them from the Democratic Party
in recent decades and therefore undone
the Democratic Party to see those facts
and not look deeper into them is I think
in a mistake of
of political journalism to some extent
last 25 years it is ridiculous that it
took a quarter century from my book to
be written should have been written by
someone a generation older and it should
have been written you know at the you
know the end of the Reagan era but it
wasn't and so I all I say in my book
above all is that the Democrats should
take an objective look at how they lost
the majority at the very moment when
they're trying to build a new one